I was a very strange child I would sit
in the basement no sound silence and I
just stood there in rock and I'd do this
for hours and hours and hours I think my
parents thought I was insane but what I
was doing is imagining futures imagining
what life could be the next step in
human evolution may not be biological
but technological by merging ourselves
with machines that augment and enhance
our physical and perceived realities but
this is no small feat I mean the human
form is a product of billions of years
of natural selection and that's why
innovators like Hugh Herr are actually
looking to nature for inspiration to
bridge the gap between man and machine
when I was 17 with my climbing partner
Jeff Bath sir we ice climb Huntington's
ravine on that Washington we got
disoriented in a complete blizzard and
spent the next several days trying to
get ourselves out to civilization we
made it within a few miles of the
roadway and we couldn't walk our lower
limbs were completely frostbitten
completely numb luckily someone was out
snowshoeing saw human tracks and we were
plucked from the mountain via helicopter
then I spent you know months in the
hospital gangrene set in was slowly
making its way on my body and it was
clear that amputation was necessary
about 12 months after my limbs are
amputated I was climbing at the same
level as I had before the accident and
people started to get nervous and then I
exceeded that level and started to climb
walls that no one ever climbed before
and then I became a threat and that
happened overnight some of my climbing
colleagues actually threatened to cut
their own legs off to achieve the same
unfair advantage as me no one actually
did it the fact that I could design my
body part and exceed what I had achieved
before it even exceed what nature
intended was very inspiring that I
realized that technology has the power
to heal to rehabilitate and to even
extend human experience and human
capability that set me on this
trajectory of a tinkering of designing
of climbing and then going back to the
shop and whittling and carving and
machining me my closet looked really
funny you didn't see shoes you saw all
these bizarre blends and feet everywhere
so what sets Hughes legs apart from the
rest
most prosthetic legs are passive and as
a result amputees have to use about 20%
more energy when walking with their
prosthetic leg Hugh and his team studied
how our leg and ankle naturally work to
create their bionic counterparts so our
case strategy and the design of Bionic
appendages is to look into nature so we
studied how the calf muscle works for
example and how the calf muscle is
controlled by the spinal cord using
neural reflexes we programmed that
capability on the small computers that
are underneath the show in the Bionic
limb so that when I walk at different
speeds and different trains it's
constantly updating the stiffness and
power it's providing me the motor mimics
our calf muscles adding positive force
to the prosthesis and that propels the
body forward this is especially helpful
for walking up ramps and stairs so that
even though the lemmas made of tight and
and all these synthetic materials it
moves as if it's made of flesh and bone
the value of closely respecting the
biophysics is that when we fit this
prosthesis
to a human body there's often no
training because the human body
remembers how to walk that's the value
of this biomimetic design approach we
build our first foot ankle in 2002 so
it's been a long iterative process
probably thirty fundamentally different
designs that led to the the banach limb
as it as it exists today we're studying
how the tissues in this part of my body
how stiff they are we're studying how
the skin moves and we then 3d print
structures that emulate those tissue
properties it looks like a topographical
map of your residual limb and it makes
for one of the most comfortable sockets
available today besides the physical
attachment to the prosthesis Hugh's team
is working on a way to control bionic
limbs more naturally they've developed
legs with EMG sensors that measure and
decode the electrical impulses in the
muscles of the residual limb and then
translate that into movement thus the
user only has to think about moving
their leg to activate the bionic limb I
have the condition that my limbs are
amputee but that condition because of
great technology I have the quality of
life that I'd seek extending that story
across all of humanity one can imagine a
world in which technologies so
remarkably great that we can eliminate
disability and I believe that will
happen in this century the toilet years
of the century there will be no
disability in the world
check out more episodes of cyborg nation
by subscribing to the wires channel